WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE CENTER PORTANTINO
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT AND WE'RE HEARING
THIS BILL PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE POINT TEN D.
BECAUSE IT WAS OF SIX OF STATE
ACTUALLY AMENDED WELL IN THE-
ASSEMBLY. SO PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU A MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TODAY I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE'S
GOVERNING BOARD. PURSUANT TO A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING TO
PROVIDE THAT APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH SHELBY GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS HOLIDAY
KNOWN AS ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
REMEMBRANCE DAY. GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SERVES A CITY
AND A REGION WITH THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF ARMENIAN
AMERICANS OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA
PROPER. AND WITHIN THAT THE
ARMENIAN DIASPORA GCC IS PROUD
THAT OVER 35% OF ITS STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE SERVING THEIR CREDIT
PROGRAM AND 48% IN THEIR NON
CREDIT PROGRAMS ARE OF ARMENIAN
ETHNICITY. FOR NUMBER OF YEARS
G. C. C.'S. ANNUALLY HAS HELD
COMMEMORATIONS IN EDUCATION
EVENTS DURING APRIL LEADING UP
TO APRIL TWENTY FOURTH WHICH AS
WE KNOW IS THE DAY. THAT THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY AROUND THE
WORLD SOLEMNLY COMMEMORATES
GENOCIDE REMEMBRANCE DAY.
TOPICS HAVE INCLUDE GENOCIDE IN
CONTEXT HISTORY AND POLITICS.
IN THE TO THE D. ASPER AND THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE. FROM FIFTH NINETEEN
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE. THE AFFECTS OF GENOCIDE
DENIAL AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
CURRENT ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. HOWEVER EIGHT ON
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH DUE TO
STATE LAW CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TRANCERS OFFICE TITLE
FIVE REGULATIONS GCC HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DECLARE A PUBLIC
HOLIDAY. SO THIS PREVENTS
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS FROM
JOINING IN ALL OF THE OTHER
GENOCIDE RECOGNITIONS IN
COMMEMORATIONS AROUND THE LA
REGION THIS IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE K. TWELVE DISTRICTS
HAVE THE ABILITY. WHICH
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT APPROPRIATELY MADE
THAT DECISION TO TAKE APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH AND COMMEMORATE
THE HOLIDAY BUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE PREVENTED FROM
THAT DISCRETION SO THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROPERLY COMMEMORATE. IT HAS
BARBED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
WITH ME I HAVE ANTHONY
CULPEPPER WHO IS EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT. FOR GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO OFFER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. THE
PORTANTINO BEFORE WE START WITH
YOUR SUPPORT WE HAVE A QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HERE LEYVA HERE WELL
PRESIDENT WILL CARE CHIANG
CHAIN HERE LASSELL RUSSELL HERE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY AND I'M CHAIR AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
PANEL WE REALLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR PORTANTINO'S SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT AS AMENDED IT IS
VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE KEY
PRINCIPLES THAT REFLECT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SYSTEM THREE THOSE PRINCIPLES
BEING THE MISSION TO MEDIUM
REFLECT THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
ANOTHER IS THE ROLE OF THE
LOCAL ELECTED BOARD OF TRUSTEES
TO KEEP THIS FOLK LOCAL FOCUS
AND THIRDLY THE IMPORTANCE OF A
CONSULTATION WITH EMPLOYEES AND
A IN ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH
THAT BEING SAID OUR
CONSTITUENCY THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY IS VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH TO CLEAR HOLIDAY
FOR THE COLLEGE SO THAT WE MAY
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO GET NOT
ONLY THE APPORTIONMENT
NECESSARY FOR COLLEGE TO
CONTINUE ITS OPERATIONS. AND IN
DOING THAT ALLOWING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE SUPPORT OF
OUR ARMENIAN COMMUNITY AS WE
REMEMBER THE TRAGEDY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE SO WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE IN INTO AN AND ASKS
THE THAT THE PANEL TO SUPPORT
SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AS AMENDED
IT DOES NOT COST THE STATE AND
LOCAL DOT TAXPAYERS ANY MONEY
IN IT DOES NOT LESSEN THE
OBLIGATION OF THE COLLEGE TO
MAINTAIN THE NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS REQUIRED BY
STATE AW. STAY REGULATION AND
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS THE
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES EXPRESSES
GREAT APPRECIATION TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN MOVING FOR THIS LEGISLATION
IT'S IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND IS COLLEGE AND URGES YOU TO
VOTE YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ANDREA BALL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE GLENDALE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT LAST NIGHT AT A
SPECIAL BOARD MEETING UPON THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S
RECOMMENDATION. THE BOARD
PASSED A RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE THANKS SENATORS
PORTANTINO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SIR ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE WILL BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE CENTER DRAWS A- THE
BILL. AND THANK SENATOR
PORTANTINO. HE'S SHOWN
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP TO THE
COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS ON
THIS. AND NOW I. OF HOPE TO BE
ALSO SUPPORTER OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE SINCE
LITTLE ARMENIA. IS LOCATED IN
MY DISTRICT. AND NOT ONLY FOR
THAT BUT FOR THE RIGHTEOUS
ISSUES THAT IT RAISES FOR
EVERYONE EVEN WITHIN AND
WITHOUT THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU. YOU CENTER ALSO
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND PORTANTINO THANK YOU
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR HAVING THIS MEETING TODAY
SO WE CAN. MOVE THIS BILL THIS
SESSION BECAUSE IT PRESENTS A%
PROBLEM FOR THE DISTRICT MOVING
FORWARD AND YOU CAN IMAGINE A
SIBLING WHERE ONE INTHE
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT GETS THE DAY OFF AND
AN OLDER SIBLING AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DOESN'T THE
FAMILY HAS TO. STRUGGLE ON THAT
DATE THAT'S A SOLEMN DAY SO
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THERE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM ONE SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
LEYVA I BELIEVE THAT I WILL.
WILK I CHANGE CHIANG I'D
RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE GLAZER
PLEASE. ARE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WE WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR A COUPLE MEMBERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU MEMBERS APPRECIATE IT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM ONE SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRENT IN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE